un petit pays de moins de 3 millions
d'habitants va accueillir le plus grand
événement footballistique du monde en
décembre 2022
rien que cette phrase suffit à faire
grincer des dents de nombreux
observateurs et passionnée de football
mais au delà des critiques sur le choix
du pays organisateur c'est aussi la
manière dont les choses se déroulent sur
place qui fait débat il ya quelques
jours le quotidien britannique the
guardian révélait ainsi avoir dénombré
grâce à diverses sources
gouvernementales pas moins de 6500
travailleurs migrants ayant perdu la vie
depuis l'attribution de la coupe du
monde au qatar
les ouvriers indiens un népalais ou
encore sri lankais qui sont morts
notamment en raison des conditions
dramatiques dans lesquelles ils
travaillent sur les chantiers de
construction des infrastructures d'un
événement un bilan terrible et très
probablement sous-estimé temps les
remontées d'informations sont
compliquées les recherches du guardian
ont également mis en évidence le manque
de transparence de rigueur et de détails
dans l'enregistrement des décès au qatar
les ambassades à doha et les
gouvernements des pays d'origine des
travailleurs hésitent à partager les
données
peut-être pour des raisons politiques un
rythme de travail effréné dans des
conditions climatiques suffocante
car si les footballeurs auront la chance
de jouer leurs matches en hiver et dans
des stades climatisés
ce n'est évidemment pas le cas des
milliers d'ouvriers venus en grande
partie d'asie du sud
du côté du comité d'organisation de la
coupe du monde au qatar on affirme je
cite regretter profondément toutes ces
tragédies
tout en contestant les allégations sur
le nombre de travailleurs décédés
d'après le qatar seuls 37 migrants
auraient perdu la vie alors si des
progrès ont été obtenus grâce notamment
à la pression des ong présentes sur
place les conditions de vie et de
travail reste à la limite de
l'acceptable
amnesty international a publié de
nombreux rapports sur ces questions
pointant entre autres l'exploitation de
milliers de travailleurs nous révélons
que des travailleurs migrants sur un
chantier de stades de la coupe du monde
de football 2022 au qatar
on travaille jusqu'à sept mois sans
salaire ce cas est la dernière
illustration accablantes de la facilité
avec laquelle il est encore possible
d'exploiter les travailleurs au qatar
face à toutes ces informations
l'autorité suprême du football la
puissante fifa est également pointée du
doigt
il faut dire qu'elle n'a jamais vraiment
haussé le ton face à des agissements
connu depuis plusieurs années il ya donc
ces chantiers de la honte mais aussi les
accusations de corruption pour
l'attribution de la compétition et enfin
ses récentes images qui ont choqué lors
d'un match organisé par la fifa à doha
la capitale qatarie deux arbitres
féminines n'avait pas pu serrer la main
d'un prince qatari présent pour la
remise des médailles des faits qui
s'accumulent et qui ne font que
renforcer la défiance envers cette
première coupe du monde organisée au
moyen-orient pour autant malgré tout
cela les délégations occidentales
restent étrangement silencieuse
indifférence ou cynisme il a toujours
été délicat d'appeler au boycott dans le
domaine sportif
ça n'avait pas empêché le royaume uni de
le faire en 2018 avant le mondial mais
cette fois là il se dérouler en russie